.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
JUMP RIGHT IN.
WHEN FAUCI KILLED SCIENCE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
NOW DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC,
HE'S HAD TIME TO DO EVERY
PODCAST, EVERY LIVE STREAM, AND
GLITZY PHOTO SHOOTS ALL FROM
UNDER THE SUN SADLY AMERICA'S
DOCTOR HASN'T JOINED US ON THE
ANGLE FOR WELL OVER A YEAR.
ALTHOUGH, THIS MORNING, I DID
HAVE THE FEELING HE WAS THINKING
ABOUT US.
>> IF YOU ARE TRYING TO, YOU
KNOW, GET AT ME AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIAL AND A SCIENTIST,
YOU'RE REALLY ATTACKING NOT ONLY
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, YOU ARE
ATTACKING SCIENCE.
AND ANYBODY THAT LOOKS AT WHAT'S
GOING ON CLEARLY SEES THAT.
YOU HAVE TO BE ASLEEP NOT TO SEE
THAT.
THAT IS WHAT'S GOING ON.
SCIENCE AND THE TRUTH ARE BEING
ATTACKED.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
IS THAT THE ARGUMENT?
HIS ARGUMENT IS ESSENTIALLY,
SORRY, I'M HOWLING LAUGHING AT
THIS.
I AM THE SCIENCE, I AM THE
TRUTH.
THAT'S HIS RESPONSE TO HIS MANY
CRITICS, WHO THEMSELVES IN MANY
CASES ARE DISTINGUISHED
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCHERS OR
TREATING PHYSICIANS WHO ACTUALLY
TREAT COVID PATIENTS?
THE MAN REALLY DOES THINK HE'S
SOME KIND OF DEITY EXCEPT THERE
WAS ONLY ONE GUY WHO HAD THE
STANDING TO SAY I AM THE WAY,
THE TRUTH, AND THE LIGHT.
AND HE'S FOUND LIKE IN THE BOOK
OF JOHN CHAPTER 14 VERSUS SIX
NOT ON MSNBC WITH CHUCK TODD.
OF COURSE FAUCI'S IS A LONG LINE
IN OUTLANDISH DEFLECTIONS.
ANYTIME HE FACES LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SCIENCE
BEHIND HIS PRONOUNCEMENTS, DR.
FAUCI SHIFTS TO HIS DEFAULT
MODE.
HE KIND OF CAVALIERLY BRUSHES
ASIDE THE QUESTION, THEN IMPLIES
HIS CRITICS ARE POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
WHEN I QUESTIONED FAUCI IN 2020
ABOUT CHINA'S LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, HE GIVE ME ANSWERS
THAT MADE NO SENSE UNLESS, OF
COURSE, HE WAS INTERESTED IN
COVERING UP FOR THE CCP.
YET, FOR THE LONGEST TIME, I
THINK FAUCI WAS ABLE TO GLIDE BY
WITH VERY LIST PUSH BACK FROM
HIS MEDIA BOOSTERS WHO
THEMSELVES SECRETLY HOPED COVID
WOULD KILL TRUMP'S CHANCES LAST
NOVEMBER.
ABOUT YOU NOW FAUCI'S ACT IS
WEARING THIN AND WE SEE TIME AND
AGAIN THAT IT WAS HE AND HIS
LIKE-MINDED EXPERTS WHO WERE
ROUTINELY ACTING AGAINST BASIC
SCIENTIFIC NORMS.
OVER THE PAST 16 MONTHS, THE
ANGLE HAS SHOW CASED SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST MINDS IN SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE, WHO'VE WEIGHED IN WITH
METICULOUS PRECISION TO BALANCE
HEALTH CONCERNS THAT WERE VERY
SERIOUS PRESENTED BY THIS VIRUS
AGAINST THE BROADER ECONOMIC
EDUCATIONAL AND SOCIAL NEEDS OF
OUR CITIZENS.
TREATING FENCE TOLD US ABOUT
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO TREAT THE
VIRUS EARLY AND CHEAPLY.
>> I THINK THE SAFETY OF THIS
COCKTAIL OF BOTH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE SPECIFICALLY
SIT ROW MAX AND ZINC IS
COMPELLING AND SHOULD REASSURE
EVERY AMERICAN.
>> I WAS VERY IMPRESSED I THINK
WE NEED TO GIVE MORE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE EARLIER TO
HELP THE OBESE PATIENTS.
WE HAVE TO GIVE THAT DRUG MORE
AND EARLIER.
>> CHEAP GENERIC AND AROUND FOR,
WHAT, 70 YEARS,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE?
BUT FAUCI AND HIS FRIENDS AT BIG
PHARMA AND THE MEDIA WOULD HAVE
NONE OF IT.
>> ANY AND ALL OF THE RANDOMIZED
PLACEBO CONTROLLED TRIALS WHICH
IS THE GOLD STANDARD OF
DETERMINING SOMETHING IS
EFFECTIVE, NONE OF THEM HAVE
SHOWN ANY EFFICACY BY
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE DOESN'T
WORK.
IT DOESN'T WORK AS A
PROPHYLACTIC.
IT DOESN'T WORK AS AN EARLY
TREATMENT.
IT DOESN'T WORK AS A LATE
>> HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE DOESN'T
WORK, AND THE PRESIDENT JUST
KEEPS COMING BACK TO AT THIS
TIME.
>> WELL, CAPTAIN FOREHEAD WAS
WRONG ALONG WITH THE REST.
THE DATA JUST PUBLISHED BY DR.
STEVEN SMITH AND ANOTHER
OBSERVATIONAL STUDY SHOWED
FAUCI'S COMMENTS LIKELY CAUSED
LIVES IN THE U.S.
WHILE WE'RE TALKING 10,000
LIVES.
>> NO, MORE THAN THAT MAN, A LOT
MORE.
>> A HUNDRED THOUSAND?
>> LAURA I HATE TO SAY THINGS
LIKE THAT, BUT, YES.
>> THEN ON HERD IMMUNITY, FAUCI
ADMITTED TO LYING ABOUT THE
THRESHOLD LEVEL FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
HE DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO FOREGO
MEDICATION OR THE VACCINE
TELLING THE NEW YORK TIMES LAST
DECEMBER, WHEN POLLS SAID ONLY
ABOUT HALF OF ALL AMERICANS
WOULD TAKE A VACCINE, I WAS
SAYING HERD IMMUNITY WOULD TAKE
70 TO 75%.
THEN WHEN NEWER SURVEYS SAID 60%
OR MORE WOULD TAKE IT, I
THOUGHT, I COULD NUDGE THIS UP A
BIT SO I WENT TO 80, 85.
THIS IS STUNNING.
SO MR. SCIENCE WAS NOT ABOUT
SCIENCE AT ALL.
IT WAS ABOUT NUDGING.
AND ON THE USUAL OF ACQUIRED OR
NATURAL IMMUNITY, IT'S WHAT YOU
GET WHEN YOU'RE EXPOSED TO COVID
YOU PRODUCE T CELLS, ANTIBODIES,
YOU CONTRACT THE VIRUS.
WELL, FAUCI ONCE AGAIN RESPONSE
WITH DISMISSIVENESS.
>> VACCINES ARE HIGHLY
EFFICACIOUS.
THEY ARE BETTER THAN THE
TRADITIONAL RESPONSE YOU GET
FROM NATURAL INFECTION.
>> OH, MY GOD.
WRONG.
IN FACT A BOMBSHELL NEW STUDY
FROM THE CLEVELAND CLINIC
COVERING OVER 52,000 EMPLOYEES,
IS THAT GOOD ENOUGH FOR YOU,
ANTHONY?
BLOWS UP FAUCI'S PROFOUNDLY
UNSCIENTIFIC CLAIM.
RESEARCHERS FOUND NO DIFFERENCE
IN REINFECTION RATES BETWEEN
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE WHO
PREVIOUSLY CONTRACTED COVID, AND
THOSE WHO HAD BEEN VACCINATED.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT'S MEDICAL
MALPRACTICE TO FORCE VACCINES ON
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, PROBABLY MORE THAN
THAT, WHO HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN
PROTECTIVE T CELLS, B CELLS OR
COVID ANTIBODIES AGAIN FROM
PREVIOUS COVID.
THIS IS IMFOLLOWING 101.
YOU LEARN THIS IN PREMED.
YOU ONE SAYS THOSE AFFECTED BY
THE ORIGINAL SARS VIRUS STILL
HAVE T CELL IMMUNITY 17 YEARS
LATER.
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL SARS.
LOOK, IF WE HAD AN INDEPENDENT
AND HONEST MEDIA, THIS NEW
CLEVELAND STUDY WOULD BE LEADING
EVERY NIGHTLY NEWSCAST.
BUT, LIKE FAUCI, THEY'VE
COMMITTED TO THE LIE THAT EVERY
AMERICAN MUST BE VACCINATED OR
BE MADE INTO SOCIAL PARAIAHS.
>> YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
BUT YOU CAN'T GO ON WITH LIFE IN
PRE COVID SOCIETY.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND ABOUT I'M
NOT GOING TO GET THE VACCINE.
BE A PATRIOT, PROTECT OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> I SAY WE NEED TO SHUN THOSE
THAT REFUSE TO GET VACCINATED.
>> SPEAKING OF VACCINES, FAUCI'S
ALSO FIGHTING THE SCIENCE ON
KIDS VACCINES AND COVID.
>> WE HOPE THAT, AS WE APPROACH
THE END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR,
WE'LL HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION TO
VACCINATE CHILDREN OF ANY AGE.
>> OKAY, THIS IS LITERALLY
INSANE AND ANTI SCIENCE.
IT WILL HELP NO ONE EXCEPT THE
PHARMA EXECS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BECOME BILLIONAIRES.
>> WE PROCEED TOKED THOSE MOST
AT RISK FOR COVID, SCHARFFR
CHILDREN ARE NOT AT RISKMENT
MORE CHILDREN DIED LAST YEAR
FROM THE FLU THAN COVID.
>> OF COURSE, ALL OF THE
EGREGIOUS FAUCI UNSCIENTIFIC
ACTS LOCKDOWNS WERE AMONG THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
DRAMATIC DEMON IS, IF YOU LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED IN EUROPE WHEN
THEY LOCKED DOWN OR SHUT DOWN OR
SHELTERED IN PLACE, THEY DID IT
TO THE TUNE OF 95% PLUS OF THE
COUNTRY DID THAT, REALLY
FUNCTIONALLY SHUT DOWN ONLY
ABOUT 50%.
>> OH, MY GOD.
CHECKED OUT EUROPE'S ECONOMY
LATELY COMPARED TO OURS?
I HONESTLY CANNOT BELIEVE HOW
COMPLIANT AMERICANS WERE FOR SO
SO LONG.
THERE WAS LITERALLY ZERO SCIENCE
BEHIND THESE ORDERS.
REMEMBER, IT WAS 14 DAYS TO SLOW
THE CURVE, SAVE THE HOSPITALS.
THAT WAS ALL OUT THE WINDOW.
AND I'M NOT EVEN SPEAKING ABOUT
OUR UNCONSTITUTIONAL LOSS OF
PERSONAL LIBERTY WITH LITTLE TO
NO LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
FAUCI BELOVED THE WAY THE BLUE
STATES HANDLED THINGS, REMEMBER
THE COZY RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMO'S.
LESS POWER FOR PEOPLE AND MORE
FOR PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
AND NOW CONFIRMED WHAT WE TOLD
YOU A YEAR AGO, LOCKDOWNS MADE
NO SENSE.
FOUND LITTLE CORRELATION BETWEEN
THE SEVERITY OF A NATION'S
RESTRICTIONS IN WHETHER IT
MANAGED TO CURB EXCESS
FATALITIES.
AGAIN, DEATH IS THE END POINT,
SHOULD BE, SERIOUS ILLNESS FOR
THIS VIE US.
OF COURSE, THE SAME STUDY DID
FIND A CORRELATION BETWEEN HARD
LOCKDOWNS AND DEEP ECONOMIC
PAIN, WHICH IS WHAT EUROPE IS
FACING.
AND WE SEE THE SAME DYNAMIC HERE
BETWEEN RED STATES THAT NEVER
SHUT DOWN OR REOPENED VERY
EARLY, AND BLUE STATES THAT
STAYED CLOSED.
JOBS DATA FROM APRIL SHAH IS
THAT 8 OF THE 10 STATES WITH THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE
LED BY GOP GOVERNORS.
AND TEN STATES WITH THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES HAVE DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS.
NATURALLY.
PERHAPS THERE'S NO ISSUE MORE
REVEALING OF THE FAUCI FRAUD
THAN THE ISSUE OF FACE MASKS.
THE FILTHY CHINESE MADE FACE
COVERINGS THAT LITTER THE
STREETS AND CLOG OUR GUTTERS
WERE ALWAYS ABOUT POLITICS AND
NEVER ABOUT SCIENCE.
>> I WEAR IT FOR THE REASON THAT
I BELIEVE IT IS EFFECTIVE.
I WANT TO PROTECT MYSELF AND
PROTECT OTHERS.
AND ALSO BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE
IT BE A SYMBOL FOR PEOPLE TO
SEE.
>> SO IT'S A COSTUME.
FIRST OF ALL, FAUCI ADMITTED IN
A NEWLY RELEASED E NAIL FEBRUARY
OF 2020 THAT MASKS REALLY AREN'T
EFFECTIVE WHICH IS CORRECT AND
CONFIRMED BY A HUGE STUDY ON
MASKS AND INFLUENCE A THAT THE
CDC POSTED ON ITS OWN WEB SITE
BACK IN MAY OF LAST YEAR.
ANOTHER RECENT STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF LOUISVILLE POINTS
OUT THAT MASK MANDATES IN YOUTH
ARE NOT ASSOCIATED WITH SLOWER
STATE LEVEL COVID-19 SPREAD
DURING COVID-19 GROWTH SPURTS.
BUT SINCE DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA THREW OUT SCIENCE, IN FACT
THEY THREW IT OUT LONG AGO, WE
STILL GET COMPLETELY INCOHERENT
AND UNSCIENTIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
LIKE THIS ONE FROM FAUCI'S PALS
AT THE CDC.
ATHLETIC ACTIVITIES SHOULD BE
DONE OUTDOORS WHEN POSSIBLE.
WEAR A MASK OUTDOORS IN CROWDED
SETTINGS OR IN CLOSE CONTACT,
VIGOROUS ACTIVITY LIKE PLAYING
SPORTS.
ZERO EVIDENCE OF THE VIRUS
SPREADING EFFICIENTLY OUTDOORS,
WHICH WE NEW AND TOLD YOU A YEAR
AGO.
BUT THE ENT SCIENTISTS AT THE
CDC AND ANTHONY FAUCI SIMPLY
WILL NOT LET THIS POWER GO.
THERE IT'S TOO MUCH POLITICAL
POWER AT STEAK.
AND SPEAKING OF POWER, THE
ENTIRE FIELD OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HAS BEEN SADLY, AND I THINK FOR
A LONG, LONG TIME, COMPROMISED,
IF NOT FOREVER, BY THE RESEARCH
DOLLARS FROM PHARMA AND ALSO THE
INFLUENCE OF THE CCP.
AND THAT MEANS FAUCI'S STILL
GIVING CHINA THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT OF THE VIRUS ORIGIN.
NOTICE HOW HE STARTS THIS NEXT
LITTLE SOUND BITE WITH MOST
SCIENTISTS I KNOW.
>> MOST OF THE SCIENTISTS THAT I
KNOW FEEL THAT WAY, THAT THE
MOST LIKELY ORIGIN IS A NATURAL
ORIGIN FROM AN ANIMAL TO HUMAN.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE NOT RULED OUT
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THERE COULD
HAVE BEEN A LEAK FROM THE LAB OF
THEM WORKING ON THE VIRUS.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN THAT SOMEONE
WAS INFECTED EARLY ON.
THEY BROUGHT HIM INTO THE LAB
AND IT CAME OUT OF THE LAB, BUT
IT WAS ALREADY OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY.
>> WAIT A MINUTE, MARCH OF LAST
YEAR 2020 THEY WERE SAYING THERE
WAS NO POSSIBILITY IT CAME FROM
A LAB.
NOW THEY'RE LIKE, OH, WELL, IT
COULD COME FROM A LAB.
WHICH IS IT?
DOES HE THINK WE ARE HE TOTAL
IDIOTS OR IS THIS HOW HE DOES
SCIENCE?
RANK SPECULATION DEVOID OF ANY
SERIOUS GENOMIC ANALYSIS THAT WE
COME TO EXPECT FROM PEOPLE
MAGAZINE IN AVIATOR SUNGLASSES.
I SAID IT BEFORE AND I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN, THOSE E-MAILS TO FAUCI IN
2021 WHAT THE BLUE DRESS WAS TO
CLIP NONE 1998.
AT ONE POINT FAUCI MAY BE CALLED
DESERVED TO BE CALLED AN
ESTEEMED SCIENTIST BUT NOT NOW.
HE'S A BUREAUCRAT WHO PALS
AROUND WITH GLOBAL ELITES WHEN
HE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON THE
SCIENTIFIC PR